but the people you can really learn from
are the people who are somewhat
disappointed
um if they can't if they couldn't use
your product every day
[Music]
nadia teslo thank you so much for being
on my show how are you
good nice to meet you finally definitely
thank you for being here
a vast experience in pure marketing the
ceo of shift
i want to go back before we get into you
know your your
professional journey where do you come
from and how do you
go at your journey wanting to become at
the ceo of a startup
um yeah i guess i'll so i
am canadian based in victoria bc um and
that's where
shift is has been founded and grown from
day one so the whole team is based
here on the west coast um my background
i actually moved to victoria about seven
years ago from toronto
um so i did my undergrad and schooling
um at queen's university in kingston
um and i guess before that i had moved
around a lot
growing up with my family so um
i think you know i've always been very
entrepreneurial about the way i approach
work and
um and that's kind of been a theme from
from day one for me
um i've also i think lived in a lot of
different places and that has influenced
a lot about
i think the way i work and the way i
want to work and just how i think about
work in general um
so i think yeah when i found victoria to
be honest i moved here because i thought
it was such a beautiful
city um i have some family here so there
was
uh that was kind of calling me from from
you know moving across the country
um you know in my 20s so yeah i think
you know wanting to be able to live in
victoria and build a company and sort of
um achieve all the things in my career
that i want to do
it seemed like a kind of an awesome
opportunity when i when i originally
took a job out on out in victoria to to
start building that out and um and yeah
i couldn't couldn't be happier to be
here it's a it's not a bad place to be
even
even through this covet and pandemic
we're all going through so how do you
find yourself
you know you're starting with pr and
marketing right that's you've held
several positions in that
world and before initiating
shift so what was it about that industry
that that interested you and
why i made that transition later on to
becoming the ceo of shift
yeah so um i guess the reason i got into
pr the first i remember the first time i
heard what public relations was
i was actually doing a um in university
i took a summer job at a
daycare like a montessori daycare and i
got chatting with one of the parents
that i
just seemed seemed kind of like a cool
guy and i remember he had founded his
own
pr consulting business and so that was
really my first time
uh getting any uh introduction to what
pr was i did my undergrad in political
science so
um and and i love you know i love
talking about politics and i love
you know that world of so i you know but
i also realized you know in
uh i was graduating kind of post 2008
and uh realizing political science
wasn't the you know the
direct path into the kind of job that i
wanted to get so
after talking to him i remember thinking
you know what this is such
a an amazing kind of introduction into
business and and i think a lot about
business you know it comes down to pr
and whether it's kind of business pr and
brand pr
or personal pr um it's all it's all very
important and also to
tell telling the story and the narrative
about your work or your company or
yourself
is so critical to success um so i
decided to
do a post-grad program in public
relations um
i met a bunch of amazing people through
that and it was a great network to kind
of jump start my career so that launched
me into working at a marketing agency in
toronto
um which i really enjoyed um but
ultimately i
i think i saw myself moving more into
the product side
um i think i saw the you know the highs
and lows of eight of
what it is to work in an agency and you
learn a lot and you move fast
and you really learn kind of the service
role um and you get to
exposure to so many cool brands and
products but i think i realized
uh pretty quickly that i wanted to you
know build something
um of my own and and really kind of be
be the
the person behind a brand rather than um
kind of serving
someone else's so there comes shift so
so what is shift
what are you trying to do there so shift
i think in the shortest amount of words
is a browser for work
so we started shift about three years
ago
really as a really solving for the pain
point of multiple email accounts
so um and then there's a little bit of
backstory in that shift actually spun
out of a company i was working at
so i was managing marketing across a
bunch of different brands at
a company here in victoria um and
there were a few of us that sort of uh
you know would jump on a project every
time we had
a new idea to um or you know product
idea
we would sort of fire up you know
nadia at whatever this new product idea
was so domain
and email and that meant calendar and
drive associated with
each of those so we could you know we
were we were very much
in this world of multiple email accounts
like i think i had seven or eight
at the time we launched shift um so
you know that's that's one side of the
uh the workflow pain point that we were
solving for but
we we approached shift from day one is
let's we have this pain point ourselves
let's build
um something uh to solve for this and
then
see the reaction and the response and
sort of build iteratively on the product
from there
so almost as soon as we launched shift
we started getting feedback that people
like this is amazing i also have this
pain point a lot of people
working in design or marketing or
consulting businesses where they also
kind of lived the same experience as us
um and then they but they also
you know often had extensions and apps
and basically
all these other things they were doing
at work in the browser that they wanted
to move
out um so that really fired up our
engine
and told us that we had you know early
signal of product market fit
and um and that really kind of uh the
vision for shift was much much bigger
than an email
service it was uh really a browser for
work
so when you say browser for work what
does that actually mean tangibly what is
if i go to shift right now what would i
see yeah so
you can download shift at tryship.com
it's a downloadable desktop app so it
sits on your um
on your computer just like you know if
you use the the slack
slacks desktop app um it's a similar
kind of download experience
um so it uh basically it's built on the
electron framework
um which is actually the same framework
that that slack is built on
um and you know you you download it for
free
you set it up and then we have a premium
experience that you can upgrade to if
you decide you need
you know all the apps and all the
extensions um unified search workspaces
all that so
um so really you know the the way i look
at it is
most of us now will operate you know
throughout our workday with
a browser kind of open at all times
and everyone has a very different
workflow some people open multiple
browser windows
um to you know organize their workflow
some people actually
have the um you know are consistent
about
gmail profiles and that's amazing if you
are um
and so they'll organize work and
personal and and whatever else they do
by gmail profiles other people will use
multiple browsers so safari chrome
um edge whatever it is that that you
like um
so but what we found is that this
this workflow experience is very
different for everyone
um and there's no one way that everyone
likes to work and is consistent about
working so we want to kind of give you
this flexibility with shift but also
spoon feed you a much more organized
sort of streamlined
um experience so you can actually get
work done and stop having to
kind of do the administrative um you
know a lot of there's a lot of buzz
about their like
out there about you know work about work
so trying to remove that work about work
for you so that you can actually focus
on you know do focus work and and
kind of eliminate distractions so if
you're looking at your
insights into the product and it's
interesting because you you say you're
transitioning from
pr and marketing more gravitating more
towards the product
and then really going through that
entrepreneurial process of finding
product market fed going
spinning off of different products
pivoting and then finding it finding
your sweet spot what were some of your
aha moments along the way
with shiv that you said ah i now
understand i have an insight that a lot
of others may not have right now
yeah um i think that's an interesting
one like i think it's been
very like sometimes i think about the
way we've approached the business very
much as
um horse before the cart so i think my
background in marketing
and and the company that we spun out of
there it was very much along this you
know uh
performance minded when it came to
marketing so
prove that there's product market fit
before you
over invest in um in building a cart
that
might not solve the right problem so um
it was an aha moment when and probably
the biggest aha moment
in the early days when our customers
started asking for
and very early customers started asking
for extensions and apps and basically
okay this is we want more than just
email um email's kind of a focus point
but it's not it's not our entire workday
so um
they were asking for that and you always
have to balance out i think um
running a company how much you listen to
customers and how much you
and how long you wait and how many
requests for something especially early
days need to pile up before you really
take action
but it was so clear so that was an aha
moment very early
on um i think um
you know i think now what we're working
on is really more focused on how to
how to help people work better together
in shift so this has been another
really i think aha moment um
we all have our workflows and sort of
our um
i think our individual work styles and
and with shift it's interesting because
um we talk a lot about like tab hoarding
and sort of that
um that mess that can pile up on your
computer that you actually don't want
anyone else to see
um i'm looking at a mess right now
yeah i mean by the end of a work day uh
which you're at i guess
you know you have you could have dozens
of tabs open windows
and you don't even know where your your
day started or ended and
yeah and then that's a pretty common
that shameful you just
close all of them because you just want
to start scratch you don't even want to
understand what you had over there
and you know it's off every day the same
thing
totally yeah and i think that that's so
common but there's also
sort of some shame around that um so we
wanted to help people
streamline that and also sort of better
prepare themselves for
when you're especially with all this
work from home stuff um
when you're jumping on a video call with
someone and then also
they want you to share your screen and
you you want to be you want to look and
feel prepared
so we built a layer on shift called
workspaces
and essentially you can think of that as
like a focused collection of
tabs apps bookmarks that you would
actually want to work with someone else
um on so you can easily just share it
with your collaborators and then there
you go you've got this clean
um place to get stuff done so that was a
big aha moment too is that
you know as individual as
your personal workflow every day is
we don't work in silos most of us don't
work by ourselves
and i think the more we work from home
and the more
we're forced to do zoom for everything
um
the more we kind of have to put purpose
back in in the way we work together
right i think i think it's really
interesting one of the things that i
it was fascinated by this past year in
one of my classes at stanford we read
a case study about superhuman by rahul
and a first-round
magazine and it was talking about how
he found his sort of nps score
and how he figured out what are the who
are his target customers
and how to um and how to accelerate the
growth on certain
areas of this company to target those
customers do you have any
any process that you're thinking through
how do i understand
how do i cluster my customers and how do
i really make sure i maximize on those
that really
love our product yeah
um that's interesting i think superhuman
has done an amazing job of
that and of understanding their core
audience and
um and speaking to them you know even
the onboarding flow that
um they did and and the fact that it's
really all
they force the word of mouth like i
think i think you still have to have an
introduction
to um their team in order to get
superhuman so you can't even just
download it right um which is really
interesting and i
and it really allows for that that word
of
mouth but you know across the internet
to feel a lot more authentic so um you
know
what we do is we really i mean we
definitely see demographic
um consistencies you know and groupings
of
people that we know shift will really
speak to
um but i think our audience is is very
very broad like it's
we have and and the more diverse and
broadly we can
um speak to people the better so
um you know we do things like uh onboard
like their surveys within shift where
you can
you know where we we ask things about
job title and
um and industry so that we can better
understand and better cater to
each of those people um you know we end
up seeing a lot of
um i think millennials are a huge part
of our core audience
um because so many of us have you know
a work life um maybe a side hustle and a
personal life that all
a lot of those part of those lives
happen
on the internet so you have email
accounts and calendars and apps that go
with each one so helping people organize
and make sense of that work life balance
that i think we're all trying to achieve
um so we see consistency with that but
with the onboarding process
and and even nps scores actually
superhuman did a really
interesting um survey of their users
that we
um also uh we we saw and ended up using
for our customer base as well
um where they asked um the customer base
how disappointed would you be
if you no longer had whatever product so
superhuman or shift
um and that was awesome because it's it
kind of
um the results we actually got the exact
same results with our audiences
as he had laid out in his article about
it um where
you know i think it was 25 of people
were very disappointed
if no shift 50 were somewhat
disappointed and 25 percent were not
disappointed
and those results have informed a lot of
um
what we do and who we do it for um
the key point that really stuck with me
with that is that you're always going to
have this 25
well you're not always but you really
are amazed by this 25
of kind of super fans and we get those
um
you know those ambassadors that you know
shift is their daily driver and they
can't live without it and we love those
people and we we love
talking to those people and getting
their feedback but the people you can
really learn from
are the people who are somewhat
disappointed um
if they can't if they couldn't use your
product every day so really kind of
digging into like where that somewhat
came from
um has been a great um or a very
informative
exercise for us i think one of the
things that i took away from
from doing that exploration and
understanding and and as a superhuman
fan myself
it was about understanding that it's
okay to
that it's okay to sort of give up on
certain groups and focus on others and i
think it's almost intuitive for us to
see that there's a group that really
doesn't care
and you're almost insulted that they
don't care so you want to
work to win their validity and get them
to join
to join you and you've sort of and you
don't even realize that they're they
might not be the right group to maximize
their efforts on especially as you're
a fast growing early stage startup you
can only focus so much of your energy on
certain areas
and and it's definitely important to
know where to focus them what has been
the most challenging and most rewarding
part of this journey for you
and i and one thing that i wanted to
bring up that we didn't get to discuss
was you didn't actually start out as the
ceo of shift right you started out as a
manager as a general manager there
you've proven yourself and then you then
you became the ceo but but what were
some of the biggest challenges and
rewards along the way
um yeah the i think the challenges are
kind of
tied into exactly what you just said
which is um
especially with shift like our our
audience is
basically anyone who uses a browser at
work all day
which is all of us um and and we can
we can prioritize the way we um
approach customer acquisition um which
is really
you know a big part of our competitive
edge and how we've really grown
um as fast as we had so i think um
i think it's segmenting your audience
when you have them it's it's very
exciting to have a massive audience it's
also a huge technological
or technical challenge um but it's
it's really you know finding ways to
splice and dice that audience
so you can you can tackle exactly the
most important
pieces first and speak to the most
important
audiences first so now i think you know
three years in it's
it's fun to be able to have a core
engine of people that we know we can
reach and reach very efficiently
but then consistently sort of layer on
and broaden
uh who we speak to and and how we speak
to them
so that's a big focus right now is is
really broadening that
um the second part of your question
um what was the other part i'm kind of
this way
the rewards some of the most yeah the
rewarding part about it
is i think um building a team
like building a team is so critical to
i mean ultimately you know you go from
kind of doing everything
yourself um with a couple other people
so um and then really sort of hiring
the people who are ultimately gonna
build the product
um in the later stages so i think um
it's rewarding and challenging but i
think a lot about
um you know the builder the creator the
builder and the optimizer
um and where we're at now you know we're
um
you know we have you know a significant
customer base of of people that are
using shift every day to drive their
work day
um so we have a lot of responsibility to
those people so there's a ton of
optimizations and
bug fixes and requests and customer
success
um you know tickets that we're dealing
with all day so that is a huge part of
the business now
that we have this responsibility to
these customers you're over here
but you have to keep creating and you
have to keep building so
balancing that out and then i think
ultimately identifying people on your
team
um as as one of those or some
combination of those it's definitely not
black and white and
people evolve over time but um at the
stage we're at
you know uh we do need all three of
those and
um and i think there is um you know it's
it's exciting because there's so much
opportunity
for everyone on the team to sort of
evolve into um the positions that are
best for them
um and sort of grow with the company so
yeah i think that's
that's rewarding and that's rewarding
for me i think a lot about it as
almost manifesting our own uh our own
growth
trajectory and manifesting what we want
out of our own career which has always
been sort of my driving force
100 i think i think that's just
wonderful
and i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time 20 minutes go by
very very fast
and i really appreciate it and before we
leave i have to put you on the spot one
time and i have to ask you for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself or if i ask
anybody that is working with you or for
you what are three words that
they would use to describe nadia um
i think uh probably
excitable um open-minded
and um and hard working
i love it and yeah thank you so so much
this is really great
and i can't wait to share this with the
world thank you so much michael
you